[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch rudi cerne für
den spaß hallo schön genannt und das
sind die nachrichten themen von heute
diplomatische offensive in saudi arabien
erklärt us-präsident beiden amerika
wolle schutzmacht der region bleiben
lebensgefahr in urlaubsgebieten in süd
europa brechen immer mehr brände aus ein
ende der hitzewelle ist nicht abzusehen
und in münchen sagt man servus robert
lewandowski verlässt den fc bayern
münchen nach acht jahren r wechselt zum
fc barcelona
manchmal wiegen interessen schwerer als
moral weil die usa öl brauchen und
verbündete gegen russland und china hat
der us präsident nach seinem besuch in
israel in saudi arabien weitere
gespräche geführt trotz heftiger kritik
dies der heikelste moment der ganzen
reise faust anfangs begrüßt beiden den
saudischen kronprinzen bin salman und
damit den mann den er selbst direkt für
eine grausame tat verantwortlich macht
den mord an journalisten kvg aber
traditionell sind die usa und saudi
arabien enge partner auch heute beim
golf kooperationsrat zum abschluss von
beiden nahost uhr brigitte sah
er trifft sich mit dem ägyptischen
präsidenten mit dem der vereinigten
emirate und mit anderen staatschefs sie
sind höflich miteinander aber nicht
herzlich der umgang mit dem saudischen
kronprinzen ist ein spagat hatte beiden
dem gastgeber doch damit gedroht ihn
wegen des mordes an cascioli büßen zu
lassen jetzt will beiden wieder mehr
zusammenarbeit mit saudi arabien und den
anderen acht ländern die heute in jeder
getagt habe
die usa wollen eine positive zukunft für
den nahen osten wir wollen vier partner
sein wir werden uns nicht zurückziehen
und ein vakuum hinterlassen das dann
gefüllt wird von china russland oder den
iran amerika wird durch auf prinzipien
basierende führung mitgestalten
beiden hat große pläne im gepäck
gemeinsame investitionen in saubere
energien länderübergreifende
infrastrukturprojekte die entwicklung
neuer digitale techniken und eine neue
allianz gegen den iran
die strategie dabei ist nicht ganz klar
die usa wollen dass sich die länder
gegen den iran stellen und verhandeln
gleichzeitig mit ihm in wien und doha um
das nuklear abkommen
am dringlichsten aber braucht beiden
mehr öl von saudi arabien im kampf gegen
die energiekrise und in der tat ist der
kronprinz zumindest bereit die
förderkapazitäten zu erhöhen und so
nimmt der us-präsident neben viel kritik
an seinem besuch zumindest eine gute
nachricht mit nach washington
haben wir noch mal nach bei mrt wissen
im kicker was bleibt unter dem strich
von diesem besuch
klare signale an den iran und china und
gleichzeitig eben auch ein kräftiger
schuss empörung aber die usa bleiben die
militärmacht die schutzmacht hier in der
region das ist für die golfstaaten
genauso wichtig für wieviel israel weil
es eben gegenüber dem iran die
schutzmacht sein soll amerika will die
seewege schützen sie wollen schutz geben
auch vor iranischen raketen angriffen
und nuklear waffen in den händen des
iran mit allen mitteln verhindern auch
mit einem militärschlag als letztes
mittel joe biden hat durch seine
wirtschaftsprojekte die er hier
verabredet hat auch im grunde um den
einfluss chinas ein stückweit
ausgebremst und er hat den autokraten
dieser region klar gesagt länder die
ihren bürgern erlauben kritik an den
anführern zu üben das werden die länder
sein denen die zukunft gehört wenn nur
der freie meinungsaustausch eben auch
den fortschritt ermöglicht jetzt liegt
er nach hause erscheint zufrieden zu
sein
und ist offenbar auch zuversichtlich
dass die golfstaaten eine erhebliche
erhöhung der fördermengen beschließen
werden irgendwann in den nächsten wochen
es gab keine feste zusage
das wird zwar an der empörung über sein
treffen mit dem kronprinzen nichts
ändern aber es wäre daneben realpolitik
mit konkreten ergebnissen m at wissen
live aus twitter vielen dank
zum krieg in der ost ukraine hat
russland seine truppen zuletzt vor allem
umgruppiert jetzt soll
verteidigungsminister schoigu befohlen
haben die kämpfe wieder zu verschärfen
dabei gehen die raketen angriffe
unvermindert weiter den beschuss der
millionenstadt micro hat moskau jetzt
bestätigt dabei waren vergangene nacht
drei menschen getötet und 15 verletzt
worden ziel sei nach russischen angaben
ein rüstungskonzern gewesen laut kiew
wurde aber eine belebte straße getroffen
in der ost ukraine etwa 75 kilometer
entfernt von nico ist unser reporter
dara hassanzadeh immer wieder werden
offenbar zivile ziele beschossen dara
wie erleben sie das
ja es ist wirklich so dass das
landesweit viel zu viele zivile
einschläge gibt und viel zu viele opfer
als dass man jetzt von zufall sprechen
könnte oder von kollateralschäden
wir sind hier auf dem weg nach bonn
basteln haben er und sein hotel in der
straße genommen dort findet eine
hochzeitsfeier stadt wurde jetzt zweimal
durch luftalarm unterbrochen ein
familienvater hat erzählt dass er seine
kinder in die karpaten auf ein
feriencamp geschickt hat damit sie dort
in sicherheit sind das kinderfest dort
endete im bunker die menschen hier sie
haben schon das nicht vergessen dass
putin der ukraine das existenzrecht
abspricht und der existenz die kann man
auch zerstören ohne ein land zu erobern
und das ist ein ziemlich furchtbarer
gedanke
dankeschön für diese einschätzung dara
hassanzadeh
auch eine folge dieses krieges gas droht
knapp zu werden und teurer sowieso
deswegen suchen viele nach alternativen
die zahl der mini solaranlagen für
balkon oder garten habe sich innerhalb
eines jahres mehr als verdoppelt so die
bundesnetzagentur laut spiegel und
natürlich versuchen auch unternehmen
sich zu helfen unter anderem mit
klimaschädlicher kohle oliver deuker
berichtet
felix schiller group in osnabrück dreht
sich alles um papier energieaufwendig
ist die produktion war nach jahren
stellt das unternehmen aus ökologischen
gründen komplett auf gas um legte das
alte kohlekraftwerk still jetzt wurde es
reaktiviert liefert 50 prozent der
energie sind das akute risiko dass wenn
eine gasmenge lage kommen und dass auch
wir davon betroffen sind und wir haben
mit dem kolleg es die alternative
genutzt die wir noch haben haben jetzt
rein gefahren um vorbereitet zu sein auf
den 21 juli den tag in der kommenden
woche an dem sich entscheiden wird wie
es eine energieversorgung weiter bild
kein einzelbeispiel wegen des drohenden
gas mangels beugen viele unternehmen vor
aus angst vor immensen wirtschaftlichen
schäden das bedeutet einigen
produktionen fehlt gas die menge ist
nicht der produktion muss eingestellt
werden produktionsanlagen gehen kaputt
und das hat kaskadeneffekt über andere
branchen letztlich dann auch mit massive
steigerung der arbeitslosigkeit und
sofern eine völlig andere
wirtschaftliche situation die
renaissance der kohle damit die
wirtschaft läuft für umweltschützer
schmerzlich aber unter gewissen
bedingungen vorstellbar wir dürfen diese
kohlekraftwerke im maximal ein bis zwei
jahre jetzt länger laufen lassen und
müssen diese laufzeit am ende wieder
abziehen und dann den kohle ausstieg
schneller machen so bleiben wir damit
klimaneutral
wie lange das alte kohlekraftwerk bei
der felix schiller group in osnabrück
laufen wird eine frage der verfügbarkeit
des gases und des preises
die wetter- extreme nehmen zu das
bekommt im moment süd europa drastisch
zu spüren mit hitze trockenheit und mit
waldbränden
besonders betroffen ist nach wie vor
portugal wegen der feuer gilt dort der
notstand auch spanien frankreich und
griechenland haben probleme und in
italien im beliebten badeort bibione
clown touristen vor einem waldbrand ins
meer oliver flammen berichtet
ein feuer mitten im paradies der
malerische strand von bibione wird für
viele urlauber zur falle die situation
zum albtraum die flammen breiten sich so
schnell aus dass sich einige von ihnen
nur noch ins wasser retten können sie
werden kurz darauf von der küstenwache
in sicherheit gebracht
auch spanien kämpft seit tagen mit der
hitze und gegen immer neue brenne bei
malaga mussten viele bewohner ihre
häuser verlassen ihre einzige hoffnung
die piloten der lösch-hubschrauber
mein haus ist alles was ich habe ich
hoffe es brennt nicht nieder der letzte
brand war schon sehr nahe aber sie haben
zum glück schnell reagiert fünf
hubschrauber kamen und haben das feuer
gelöscht ich bin ihnen so dankbar jede
wasserstelle wird genutzt sie fliegen
unermüdlich denn jederzeit kann die
situation eskalieren
der wind hat die flammen zwar ein stück
von meinem haus weggetrieben aber ich
habe angst dass er dreht und das feuer
zurück kommt
an manchen stellen sind die feuer auf
portugiesisches gebiet übergesprungen
auch hier können sie nur machtlos aus
der ferne zuschauen ohne löschflugzeuge
geht nichts es sind immer wieder extrem
gefährliche einsätze die einer der
piloten jetzt mit seinem leben bezahlt
hat seine einmotorige maschine stürzte
in bergigen gebiet ab für die menschen
in portugal ist der 38-jährige ein held
im kampf gegen das feuer
er gilt als mexikos drogenboss der
drogenbosse jahre lang stand raphael
caro quintero auf der fbi liste der zehn
meistgesuchten kriminellen jetzt wurde
der 69-jährige von mexikanischen marine
soldaten gefasst und soll an die usa
ausgeliefert werden die behörden dort
hatten ein kopfgeld von 20 millionen
dollar ausgesetzt quintero soll 1985 den
mord an einem us agenten der drogen
handlung angeordnet haben
als konsequenz aus dem antisemitismus
skandal bei der documenta hat die
generaldirektorin sabine schormann ihr
amt niedergelegt bei der eröffnung der
kunstausstellung vor einem monat war
auch ein banner mit judenfeindlicher
bildsprache gezeigt worden das werk
indonesische künstler wurde abgehängt
bereits vor der documenta gab es
antisemitismus vorwürfe gegen die
kuratoren der schau
wenn die ferien fliegt ist meist
urlaubsreif und braucht doch am
flughafen noch mal gute nerven nach wie
vor geht es stundenlange wartezeiten
einzuplanen auch heute wieder es fehlt
an personal tausende flüge mussten schon
gestrichen werden und eine echte lösung
ist nicht in sicht auge wurde
für familie jena geht es heute in die
ferien das ziel zypern doch am flughafen
düsseldorf will heute morgen nicht so
richtig das erhoffte urlaubsfeeling
aufkommen bei fünf stunden wartezeit
mussten und das ist nervig wenn man
kleine kinder hat man freut sich drauf
und im nachhinein denkt man sich wow
unorganisiert grund für die
stundenlangen wartezeiten ist noch immer
der personalmangel vor allem bei den
sicherheitskontrollen auch an diesem
wochenende werden allein von düsseldorf
aus knapp 200.000 menschen in den urlaub
statten die nehmen es sportlich aber
nicht alle
jetzt geht es ja schon weiter gekommen
sind voller stunde standards meter
weiter da habe ich schon ein bisschen
dass plänen augen da habe ich gesagt wir
haben sogar eine verkehrten stelle
gespart es mit dem personal
aber ich nehme es wieder das wetter es
ist so wie es ist am frankfurter
flughafen hat man kurz vor dem
ferienbeginn in hessen jetzt schon sorge
vor noch mehr chaos daher sollen ab der
kommenden woche die flugbewegungen pro
stunde deutlich reduziert werden heißt
im klartext weitere flugausfälle und
auch bei den pilotinnen und piloten
wächst die sorge dass sich das chaos am
boden bis ins cockpit auswirkt denn
immer mehr verspätete flüge und
wartezeiten sorgen für stress und
längere arbeitszeiten
hat der gesetzgeber einen
sicherheitsgurt eingebaut übermüdete
groß dürfen nicht fliegen das heißt für
ihren flug sie benötigen eventuell eine
ersatzcrew und diese wiederum ist
aktuell nicht verfügbar oder selbst
übermüdet so dass der flug nicht wie
geplant stattfinden kann bis sich die
lage durch zusätzliches personal wieder
entspannt wird es noch einige wochen
dauern die sommerferien sind dann
allerdings schon längst vorbei
eine alternative wäre aufs fliegen
verzichten und urlaub in der heimat
machen zum beispiel an den stränden
mecklenburg vorpommerns die sind begehrt
als urlaubsziel und doch zeigt sich auch
hier die veränderte weltlage viele gäste
schauen mehr aufs geld und manche kommen
gar nicht mehr aus stralsund berichtet
anne stadt fällt das tor zur insel rügen
mit besonderer backsteingotik stralsund
platz denn der hochsaison eigentlich aus
allen nähten derzeit sind aber noch
viele zimmer frei allein im hotel
scheele hof etwa 20 prozent inflation
und steigende energiekosten schrecken
mögliche gäste ab sagt der direktor die
verunsicherung ist einfach da weil man
am ende des tages nicht weiß habe ich
überhaupt das geld um mir noch einen
urlaub leisten zu können aber nicht nur
bei den zimmerbuchungen sind einige
zögerlich kröger spürt auch
umsatzeinbußen im restaurant vielleicht
wird ja aperitif mal weggelassen
vielleicht wird eine günstigere flasche
wein gewählt also jeder hält seinen euro
so ein stück weit noch fest vielerorts
entlang der ostseeküste in mecklenburg
vorpommern haben hotels ihre preise
deutlich gesenkt manchmal sogar um die
hälfte
besonders familien achten im urlaub
derzeit aufs feld man guckt schon drauf
und gut beim essengehen schon drauf was
kostet wie viel wo es was wir haben uns
gedacht wir vor uns liegt es ja
vielleicht so gut wie gar nichts mehr
leisten können wir dieses jahr noch mal
los gut besucht sind derzeit noch
sehenswürdigkeiten wie das ozeaneum in
stralsund allerdings droht auch hier ein
starker besucherrückgang wir haben
natürlich sorge dass im kommenden jahr
wenn die menschen dann ihre
energiekosten abrechnung bekommen ihr
geld lieber eben dafür verwenden oder
verwenden müssen finstere aussichten für
die tourismusbranche mit angeboten und
rabatten hofft hoteldirektor krüger
seine freien zimmer doch noch
auszulasten vielleicht auch eine
strategie für das nächste jahr
die strategie von robert lewandowski ist
aufgegangen er verlässt die bayern genau
hat sich lange hingezogen
er wechselt also vom fc bayern münchen
zum fc barcelona nach zähen
verhandlungen haben sich die bayern mit
den katalanen angeblich auf eine ablöse
in höhe von 45 millionen euro plus 5
millionen an möglichen bonuszahlungen
gar nicht ein paar umarmungen beim
vormittagstraining so unspektakulär
enten acht jahre bayern münchen bei der
teampräsentation am nachmittag ist
robert lewandowski schon nicht mehr
dabei das robert hier für den fc bayern
auch geleistet hat in seiner zeit es ist
ja mehr als mehr als outstanding er hat
ihr alles gewonnen hat seinen teil dazu
beigetragen
zu vielen titeln der 33-jährige hat
allein in der vergangenen saison 50
pflichtspiel tore für den rekordmeister
geschossen ersetzen so lewandowski unter
anderem seit juni vom fc liverpool
zudem verlängerte seinen vertrag bis
und deutschlands fußball frauen treffen
heute bei der em im letzten gruppenspiel
auf finnlands nach zwei siegen ist die
mannschaft als gruppen-erster bereits
für das viertelfinale qualifiziert katja
stresow in milton keynes mit welcher
einstellung schickt die bundestrainerin
die mannschaft denn auf den rasen
rudi das ziel ist natürlich ganz klar
auch das dritte vorrundenspiel soll
gewonnen werden möglichst natürlich
wieder zu null martina voss tecklenburg
wird die startelf im vergleich zu den
ersten beiden spielen ein bisschen
verändern zum einen sind zwei spielerin
gelbgesperrt dann darf wieder magull
ihren leicht lädierten oberschenkel ein
bisschen schon und martina voss
tecklenburg hat auch gesagt sie will
alles allen spielerinnen heute mal
einsatzzeit können das heißt sarah dort
wird erstmals heute auf dem platz stehen
von beginn an in der innenverteidigung
21 usd anpfiff in milton keynes finnland
gegen deutschland bestimmen sie aber
gern schon ein ab 20 15 im zdf
sportstudio live
vielen dank katja also dann bis nachher
erster tag der leichtathletik-wm in
eugene oregon ganz im zeichen von stars
and stripes die erste wm auf us
amerikanischem boden aber am ende wird
es nicht dass vierzehnter wm-gold für
essen felix die erste wm auf us boden
ist erwartet patriotisch und soll
medaillen trächtig werden für die
gastgeberinnen aber gerade über 4 x 400
meter mixed kann alles ein felix nicht
den 14 das wm-gold gewinnen zum
abschluss ihrer karriere schlussläuferin
kenne die samen geht gegen die
dominikanische republik die luft aus
platz drei noch hinter den niederlanden
doppelsieg über 20 kilometer gehen
dagegen für japan vom schwedischen
bronzegewinner gewürdigt christopher
linke olympia fünfter gab auf und die
100 meter us-sprinter fred carroll in
topform vorlauf 9 79 sekunden seit
youtube und war keiner mehr so früh vor
allem finale so stellen
und michael matthews gewinnt die
vierzehnte etappe der tour de france der
australier holt sich nach 192,5
kilometer den sieg vor dem italiener
weiter in gelb der däne jonas winklbauer
der berliner simon geschke sichert sich
zum sechsten mal nacheinander das
bergtrikot so oft wie kein anderer
deutscher zuvor
das war's vom sport dankeschön bevor uns
kommende woche die große hitze in den
schwitzkasten nimmt wird es morgen noch
mal relativ angenehm im norden mehr
wolken im süden sonne hat mehr gleich
von katja honnefer das heute-journal in
der halbzeitpause gegen viertel vor zehn
mit christian sievers danke für ihr
interesse ein schönes wochenende ihnen
noch und bis morgen wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend der hitze höhepunkt wird
wohl schon am dienstag in der kommenden
woche erreicht dann können hier im
westlichen mitteleuropa durchaus 40 oder
41 grad erreicht werden wäre schön wenn
wir die tiefen temperaturen der
kommenden nacht irgendwie konservieren
könnten denn da wird frisch mit 14 grad
am oberrhein und 6 grad zum beispiel im
vogtland im süden ist es häufig klar im
norden gibt es dichtere wolken und das
setzt sich auch morgen über tag fort
also mehr wolken in norddeutschland und
mehr sonne im süden entsprechend
unterschiedlich sind die temperaturen
mit west wind und wolken bleibt es an
den küsten von nord- und ostsee recht
kühl bei 19 bis 22 grad sonst werden auf
22 bis 25 grad erreicht in der
südwesthälfte sind es 24 bis 32 grad und
dann wird es heiß schon am montag gegen
die höchsttemperaturen bei 23 bis 36
grad und am dienstag kommt die hitze
dann auch an der küste an dann gibt es
dort zu um die 27 grad und im westen
deutschlands könnte es für 40 grad
reichen vielleicht auch irgendwo für 41
grad in der nacht zum mittwoch und
mittwoch über tag kommen dann gewitter
von westen und vertreiben die hitze
ostwärts schönes wochenende noch